hey Lolly I love service Computing and
Cloud run but does anyone else
it's Martin I work with the organization
every day who use cloud run for business
critical workloads let me tell you why
they pick cloudron
[Music]
I'm so glad that you could join me on
the show today Lolly uh what do you do
for a living I'm customer engineer based
in
fixing so you are really in the trenches
helping customers put real world
workloads in the cloud
yes that
way of putting it many of them
in the cloud all right so why do they
pick Cloud run I can't talk about some
real customer examples
simplicity
and cost efficiency Simplicity was item
one on your list now I love Simplicity
but what do customers say about cloudron
and simplicity I heard from a team at
Android which is a Swedish tech company
they provide price transportation that
is a digital electorate and autonomous
think full-size electric autonomous
trucks they told me that Claude run let
them abstract away Cloud Resource
Management which get them higher
utilization and more efficient cloud
system
right if you're using Cloud run Google
spins up and down Services needed to
match your traffic
that's great because we developers have
enough to think about already
I've also heard at the team at Karma
they said that cloud run streamlines
their infrastructure management this
gives them more time to focus on
important things like planning their
expansion in the UK and France and you
told me before we recorded this that
Karma builds a software for restaurants
yes car
all these activities are climate
compensated this here is up time for
this stuff so they can offer better
service to guests and if the restaurant
has a food left at the end of the day it
can be sold at discount ensuring less
food based all right sounds good item
number two on your list was developer
productivity what are customers saying
about that well have you heard of Ikea
it's 3D furniture and home good
retailers of course I'm standing at an
Ikea desk right now using managed
services like Google Cloud run Ikea
retail has been able to adopt and grow
in the cloud
Kia's culture is developer supportive
the developer team was able to research
and convince the company that managed
services in the cloud was the way to go
I agree if you want to maximize
developer productivity let Google worry
about server maintenance also a global
Swedish fashion retailer is using Cloud
run to a large extent for the same
reason the last item on my list was cost
efficiency yeah I was a bit surprised by
that Lolly because some people say that
serverless Computing is more expensive
than managing your own servers oh well
it
depending shot
story and migrated to cloudron they got
that constant phone call from their
reseller the reseller had noticed that
in right total cloud has been had
dropped dramatically uh well I guess it
depends on what your workload is if your
workload is scientific Computing your
server CPU may be running at 80
utilization 24 7. but many companies
don't have workloads that keep their
service that busy all the time right
many workloads vary with the time of a
day and the day of week those workloads
can be more affordable to run on cloud
run because it is scale up and down with
your load automatically it even is
scaled down to a zero so you don't pay
if there is no traffic yeah and Cloud
run gives you the peace of mind that
your system will scale up to meet
increased traffic like on Black Friday
or if you are featured by Techtron yes
indeed and there's more to cost than
just your Cloud bill right
yes several customers I have talked with
say that the total cost of ownership is
lower with the cloud run that's because
their developer can spend more time on
the building near future and less time
on just keep the system running all
right Lily thanks for sharing these
customer quotes with us today
running down listen to customer ah those
are wise words and thank you everyone
for watching if you have questions about
how organizations use cloud Run please
add them to the comments below also let
us know if there are other serverless
topics you'd like to hear about in
future episodes we read every single
comment
until next time
[Music]